what about you do you think it could
have evolved in an entirely different
way and retained some of that openness
and sense of boundless freedom there
well I mean I'm not a historical
determinist so yes of course lots of
different things could have happened I
mean I believe in the adjacent possible
so people have ideas for things like
airplanes at periodic intervals through
the whole of human history but
eventually some of those ideas get
realized because we have material
science and physics to kind of catch up
with it which is what when people say
you get railroads when it's railroading
time they don't mean that there's a
mystical railroading energy in the air
they just mean that we have now attained
the point where when that idea occurs
with it's on scheduled regularity that's
some of the people to whom it occurs
we'll be able to figure out how to make
it a reality so I don't think we run on
Rails I think we have lots of moments in
our history where things have gone well
and some where they've gone poorly when
the World Wide Web Consortium decided
that members who participated in
standard setting would have to observe
web patents so there would be no toll
gates for producing web technology that
was a key juncture it could have gone a
different way it could have been much
worse but on the other hand when the
Digital Millennium Copyright Act was
passed in 98 and when the European Union
copyright directive was passed in 2001
both of them produce extraordinarily bad
policy that if we hadn't had it I think
things would be much better they both
provide for among other things an
unaccountable system of arbitrary
censorship and a rule prohibiting
disclosing security vulnerabilities in
technologies that we rely on which could
have produced which which does present a
clear and present danger to us and which
is only going to get worse unless we can
do something about it
you